back in the 90s most people took Pluto
for granted fast forward to 2006
suddenly Pluto was all Americans were
talking about
or rather yelling about some people were
so angry they were giving astronomers
death threats people were so angry that
they said that all the stronger should
be put on the wall on the wall in
uncharted that's tellement man he's
former general secretary for the
International Astronomical Union the
same organization of the world's
astronomers that changed Pluto's status
from Planet to dwarf planet in 2006 and
today over 12 years later people still
have strong opinions whenever you ask
should Pluto be a planet again
[Music]
yes no no yeah yes no yes I'm not really
sure that I have an opinion of whether
or not Kudo should be a planet there's
obviously some confusion going on here
so we did the next logical step we went
to the experts to settle this once and
for all that's Alan Stern he leads
NASA's new Horizons mission which flew
by Pluto in 2015 and in planetary
science were the experts in planets are
we call small planets planets we call
large moons planets we call all the
planets around other stars planets and
the astronomers definition wouldn't
allow any of those to be planets okay so
basically Stern says it depends on
context but why back in the early 90s
Pluto was a planet period no context
needed so what changed by the late 90s
it was becoming clear that Pluto wasn't
alone astronomers had discovered other
worlds in the
same region called the Kuiper belt and
some of them looked awfully similar to
Pluto
then in 2005 astronomers discovered Eris
which estimates at the time suggested
was even larger than Pluto on January
8th of this year while looking through
some old data that we had taken with the
Samuel ocean telescope at Palomar
Observatory we found much to our
surprise an object three times further
away than Pluto this will absolutely
rewrite the history of astronomy
textbooks and while these new worlds
looked and behaved like Pluto they were
completely different from every other
planet in our solar system something had
to be done it was clear that astronomers
were in need of something they never had
before a good definition for what makes
a planet a planet so in the wake of
these new discoveries the IAU came up
with a checklist a planet must orbit the
Sun have a nearly round shape and have
cleared its neighborhood meaning no
other large objects are nearby and that
last requirement boots Pluto off team
planet yes it orbits the Sun yes it's
spherical but Pluto isn't always the
dominant gravitational force in this
neighborhood for one thing
Eris shares the region and isn't stuck
in Pluto's orbit the end result
Pluto was bumped from Planet to dwarf
planet NOW Stern argues that a dwarf
planet is a kind of planet just like how
the bonsai tree is still a tree and a
chihuahua is still a dog but other
experts like mad prefer to think of
dwarf planets as their own class so
where does that leave us
well in the grand scheme of things it
doesn't really matter what Pluto is
official
nation is if people don't like it they
don't use it period
which is exactly what planetary
scientists do so everyone's using the
planetary scientists definition in the
written refereed scientific literature
and using it at the podium in giving
scientific presentations that's the kind
of consensus that's very powerful in
science so maybe Pluto isn't a planet
the same way that Earth and Jupiter are
planets but that doesn't mean we should
ignore it besides there's more to this
dwarf planet than meets the eye the New
Horizons mission has found evidence of
ice volcanoes hidden oceans there are
evidence for ice Falls and floes and
glaciers just tremendous stuff and
that's true no matter what you call it